When we get additional supplements recommended with our genetic report, are those correlated
with the previous cheek swab recommendations?
So I was given PUN one assist and AI after the genetics, no, that's totally based upon
your genetics and okay, so let's finish question because I remember you saying it just because
you have a problem with the gene doesn't mean it's affecting the cancer, like I have a couple
other variants that can't elevate whole assisted blood pressure, but I have neither symptom.
I'm just trying to prioritize expenses. I'm assuming that the first recommendations are
enough to cover what seems to be relevant genetic information, but I don't know how to
tell which ones are affecting my cancer the most.
So I would agree if you, you know, if finances are an issue and you want to drop supplements,
I'd drop the genetic ones first.
Your PUN, the PUN one assist or what we have probably labeled as phase two is really supporting
your phase two pathways. That is really, I tell you, talk about correlative and I don't
know who caused it to affect, but the PUN one pathway with breast cancer is just like amazing.
There's actually a lot of research that's coming out about PUN with defects with breast cancer
and it's just correlative, but it's not necessarily cause, it's a huge correlation.
So I would drop the AI, I would keep the PUN one assist if you can.